et puis depuis hier soir nous vous
proposons de faire connaissance avec les
épouses des candidats celles qu'on a
l'habitude de voir dans les mting au
côté de leur Marie mais qui parle peu
hier Patrick Carolis vous propos un
portrait d'Iliane marché ce soir nous
vous proposons de mieux connaître Daniel
mitan et Bernadette Chirac jaquim
Collins a suivi Bernadette Chirac pardon
dans ses déplacements nous la présente
dans ses deux grands rôles le conseiller
général en corise et la femme du maire
de
Paris à l'occasion de cette réunion vous
vous en souvenez messieurs les maires
vous étiez présents pour la plupart
conseiller municipal de s depu 10 ans
conseiller général du canton de corè
depuis
1979 on ne sait pas toujours Bernadette
Chirac a elle-même une réelle activité
politique ces spécialités les questions
d'équipement de communication d'hygiène
mais elle et ses deux filles ne
participent pas directement à la
campagne de Jac pr et bien les Français
vont élire un
président et non pas une famille
présidentielle je crois par conséquent
que mon rôle doit rester d'une grande
réserve et d'une grande discrétion elle
n'est cependant pas indifférente à la
campagne de son mari je m'y intéresse
beaucoup j'en suis le déroulement je
j'accompagne mon mari dans certaines
réunions mais je crois que mon rôle
n'est pas du tout de jouer au conseiller
politique je participe à certaines
réunions je l'ai accompagné aux
gentilles à la Martinique à la
boiseloup aux réunions qu'il tient
naturellement dans le
Lina je dois justifier la décision que
j'ai prise il y a 2 mois mais je cherche
à créer autour de lui un climat
psychologique aussi favorable que
possible quand il rentre de ces journées
très fatigantes dans ce combat
particulièrement difficile une ambiance
de détente propice à la réflexion et au
repos cette très belle expos
[Musique]
regoupe consiste surtout à poursuivre
mes activités habituelles de femmes de
mer de Paris qui sont déjà très
prenantes la vie de paris continue elle
est très cette grande capitale donne
beaucoup d'activités si on veut vraiment
s'y
intéresser merci d'avoir reçu chez vous
aujourd'hui son travail électoral le
plus concret se fait en cor où elle se
rend
régulièrement j'ai un contact facile j
vais trs régul
presque toutes les semaines il y a même
des semaines où j'y vais deux fois par
le train ou au volant de ma propre
voiture j'accomplis un certain nombre de
visites
domiciliiresê un beau soleil ou Fas
magnifique je reçois un très abondant
courrier de toute la France même de
l'étranger les gens espèrent que je
pourrais transmettre au candidats un
certain nombre de messages sur le
déroulement de la campagne tes
correspondances sont un reflet de
l'opinion publique
j'y réponds toujours en tout cas